goto to new research teens now prefer
texting over talking in person and other
news water is wet puppies are adorable
and I could have been a male model so
why does this matter
well while most teens think that social
media improves their lives for those who
have poor social well-being it's
actually the opposite part of this is
due to the ease at which Anonymous mobs
can form an attack online because people
tend to imitate each other in order to
belong social media is now a constant
exercise of swarm and shame when a large
number of people do this simultaneously
its mob behavior a pack of hyenas
screaming for a scalp the strong can
handle this but the vulnerable not so
much spend five minutes on Twitter
you'll see it so I'm all for texting but
by removing face-to-face content contact
and the vulnerability of eye contact
it's just easier to destroy each other
a generation becomes a mob of Cruelty
out to punish someone for their own sins
think about Christ the original
crucifixion was meant to be the last one
the one to stop the mob then came the
iPhone and Twitter
now we crucify daily so here's my advice
for parents of teens because I am the
expert at every chance help them see the
reality of their anger and the reality
of a mob and why it's brave to egg on
its failure destroying a life online is
an act of craven self scarring and
eventually that's how the world will see
you as just another coward yelling
crucify him wow I can't believe this
this is too much amen brother I can't
believe you and I are on the same but I
think human interaction is being
actually derailed by these systems I
agree I agree and I think that's why
it's that's why it's like when you see
something like the Debra Messing thing
it was easier for her to go after a peer
basically who agrees with her because
they're not acting like you can't talk
to certain people in a face-to-face way
the way you do it here you can destroy
somebody you also don't have context yes
in any sort of digital communication so
it's difficult to tell if someone really
is upset or if someone really is being
sarcastic right if you take that the
wrong way you can ruin a friendship I'm
both my daughters have devices where
they are able to text and there's a lot
of parental control don't get me wrong
but it's scary because you don't want
your kids to be antisocial and
dehumanized and there's something very
human about reading the signals on
someone else's face exactly that's
that's how we evolved in order to read
those subtleties and modify our behavior
accordingly so human interaction then is
at a moment it's almost like a fork in
the road because what we've said in the
polls is the kids prefer texting yeah so
human contact but then when they're with
each other a high percentage say well my
friends are distracted they're paying
attention the phones a second than me
yeah but but the human interaction
something different is going on yeah all
I know it's the only times I've had to
apologize in my life recently is after
emails or texts or tweets because I get
angry at something that it probably
would have been angry if I had been
iContact or something it's weird right
because also if you'd send an email that
sounds mean you we don't know that you
might have like if you had said it out
loud you probably would have laughed yes
like that's how you communicate is what
you put lol Dana gave up social media
for Lent uh-huh and she loved the
freedom that it gave her and she never
went back that's great she was 15 Wow
it's here to stay there's nothing we're
going to do about technology and social
media it will continue to evolve it's
just really important as parents that
you know you have to redirect your kid
you have to take them outside and you
have to constantly encourage them but
the nice thing about a phone for a
thirteen-year-old is it as a great
discipline device and the second there's
misbehavior
take it away did something what's gonna
happen is eventually you're gonna get a
generation of kids with hunchbacks yeah
you're gonna be like this posture and
blind they're gonna be blind hunchbacks
everything really jittery with no
attention span and they're not going to
be married because they can't score at a
bar yeah but the upside is if they're
blind and hunched back they could just
go to Notre Dame
that joke rings a bell nice
but should we end it there I probably
said